hi there i have a little challenge for
you
right here look at these numbers and see
if you can figure out what comes
where the question mark is now if you
look
at it a little bit you'll recognize that
this
is the sorting algorithm so you're
supposed to
sort these numbers in ascending order
and that's going to be the solution and
the why i'm showing you this isn't
because it's particularly hard or
because i'm particularly
good at sorting numbers it is because
this is a core feature of human
intelligence that we haven't been able
to reach with machine learning
quite yet we are able to look at very
few examples and then generalize to new
examples and we do that not by the way
machine learning does it by you know
gradient descent into a model
but we do it by coming up with a rule
such
as hey this is sorting even if we didn't
know what sorting was
we would be able to come up with the
rule nevertheless
because we would realize you know i need
to compare the numbers and i need to
pick the lowest
one first and then the second lowest one
second
and so on so we humans
are able to come up with rules to solve
the problem
and in more general sense we're able to
come up with a
program with an algorithm that solves
the problem
and that is the point of this paper
to solve problems not with pure brute
force machine learning like gradient
descent from a data set
but with coming up with rules with
algorithms to solve
the problem now this brings its inherent
challenges it's not a new approach
but this paper makes it more scalable
than before so the paper is called
dreamcoder
growing generalizable interpretable
knowledge
with wake sleep bayesian program
learning it's by kevin ellis catherine
wong maxwell nye
matthias abel meyer lucari luca morale
luck hewitt armando solar lessema and
joshua b tenbaum so
again the program the the paper says
itself
we present dreamcoder a system
that learns to solve problems by writing
programs it builds expertise
by creating programming languages for
expressing domain concepts together
with neural networks to guide the search
for programs within these languages
so the entire model is going to be a
system
that sees problems just few of them
and comes up with programs that solve
these problems and
and it does so in its own language it
builds up its own programming language
and then it's able to synthesize
programs in this language
that solve the the problem
and it does so by having a neural
network guide that
search so that's dream coder it includes
this
wake sleep algorithm which has been also
around for a while
but it's it's kind of a different take
on it the wake sleep
learning algorithm alternatively extends
the language with new symbolic
abstractions
and trains the neural network on
imagined and replayed
problems so the past
ventures into program synthesis have
all been not really scalable because
either they have some kind of
handcrafted programming language that
you search over
or they have handcrafted rules of how
you search
and so on this system here is much more
general
and it can solve a vast variety of
different
tasks so for example here you can see
the different types of tasks that the
system can solve there is
list processing oh sorry that's a bit
heavy there's list processing
such as summing lists doubling each
element
check for evens uh text editing
uh learning reg access for stuff and
also very creative things like creating
graphics
um creating block towers regressing
symbolically
recursive programming and figuring out
physical laws
we've already looked at paper that
figure out physical laws from data but
they have been
sort of geared towards that and this
is the same system that can figure out
all of these things now of course it's
going to be
configured a little bit differently if
you talk about list
processing versus figuring out physical
laws
but it is the same underlying system
and ultimately what is that what does
that amount to
that amounts to you giving the
you giving the system a
problem and let's say the problem right
here
is what do we have here to sort a list
yeah that's what we came up with at the
beginning so here you have the problem
of sorting a list
so you're going to give the program a
few examples
like three like i gave you at the
beginning and
the the system is going to come up with
a program
now the program ultimately is going to
look like the thing
down here it's going to come up with a
program
that implements the list sorting
algorithm
and it's going to do that with by a few
principles
so principle one of course it needs to
fit all of the examples it needs to
explain all of the examples otherwise
it's not a correct program
and program sorry concept two
is it needs to be easy it needs to be
very very uh explainable
in the sense of it needs to be very
short because there
are many different rules that
you know these these uh lists follow
like i can i can come up with i can
literally create this
as a hash table i can implement this as
a hash table for these three lists
and that hash table would solve the
problem
exactly as well as the sorting algorithm
now the sorting algorithm is much more
compact it's simply
it's well it's this thing down here and
beyond that what the what the
system does is it builds up a library of
concepts
so not only not only the system doesn't
see the program at the bottom the system
actually
sees this program right here so this
is the sorting algorithm in the systems
language because
the system has built up a learned
library of concepts
over time so as we train the system to
solve
different tasks on lists such as you
know
sum a few things double a few things and
so on
it builds up this library of concepts
so there are these primitives right here
that you give it
and then it's able to come up with these
concepts
that we as programmers might call
functions
so it's able to come up with a thing
that can filter a list
it doesn't have it in its initial
primitives but it's able to discover
that
because it uses it again and again and
again and now it's able
to use that function instead of the
primitives
so whereas before you know it would have
to it would have used the entire code in
this thing
now it's just able to say well i want to
use concept 4
right here and that makes the programs
that
are written much shorter so
it uses this to implement the maximum
function which it calls it concept 13.
of course it has no
concept of what we name function uh and
then it's
able to use concept 13 and concept 4
together
to implement the nth largest element
function right and once i have the nth
largest element function
i can simply iterate from the beginning
right
i have a list i simply iterate over its
length
so i iterate that and i always use the
nth
largest number and that will sort my
list
so you can see that the program that
sorts the list
is super short in terms of this library
we've built up so this this is our
challenge for building this system we
somehow need a system
that is able to come up with programs to
solve
problems that is able to build up a
library
and that is able to efficiently search
through
that self-built up library of concept
and dreamcoder does all of this at the
same time
so dreamcoder has three different stages
in which these things are tackled so
imagine
you have a data set of tasks
so the tasks here are these x's
okay so x are the tasks
now the tasks can either be as
i understand it of a single thing like
list
sorting right but they can also be
the general class of list problems which
makes more sense in our in our uh class
so imagine we have a kind of the the
general
the general class of list sorry the the
general class of list
problems now
it maintains as we said this library
l and you can really imagine this
as a programming library so it contains
functions that the program
can call and it also contains all the
primitives that you give it so
there are going to be a bunch of so this
is going to be
like a set they're going to be a bunch
of primitives
like a plus b a minus b
a times b in that's in in terms of math
right here we're in lists but
and there's also going to be a section
down here that the program can fill
itself
so the program can define a function
that's like
2a plus b right and then it
it's able to to call that so that's the
library
right here now what the
what the system needs to do is it's
given a task
so the task here as you can see is a few
examples of
i don't even know what it does here
do you know what it does it kind of
reverses the list
and adds one or subtracts one
something like this yeah i think it
reverses the list and then it adds one
right that's the that's the task that we
we handle right here
right this uh you can see all of these
things is reversing
and adding i have i've actually not
solved that before so it might be wrong
so what we have to do is we have to come
up with a program
that solves these tasks right that
if we give the left side as an input the
right side
appears and that is
hard that is a hard problem because you
know we start
right here with an empty program and we
build up a search tree
now every single one of those rules here
could be applied right so the program uh
could
be you know let's take let's take
the or yeah let's let's say these are
not math
things but these are our list things so
um i guess reversing is one of them
map is another one but you you get the
point so you have
you put these rules here and you apply
you could apply the first rule right you
could build a program
made up out of the first rule you could
build a program
made up of the second or the third now
if you already have so here your program
is a plus b
if you have that you could then again
apply
the first rule which would give you
a plus sorry a plus a plus b
you could apply the second rule which
would give you
um a plus
a minus b right i'm just substituting
kind of the the second element
right here this is obviously implemented
in
a functional programming language that
makes all of this
really well defined i'm just kind of uh
showing it for in in easy mode right but
you get the point like i can
arbitrarily search through this tree and
i can apply
each of those rules over and over and
over again and you can already see that
this is going to give me a massive
search tree uh like how am i gonna solve
these problems in in these kind of
massive trees
and that's where the neural network
comes in
it's actually the only part in the
system that is machine learned as
far as i understand it or at least that
is
neural networked machine learning isn't
only deep learning but this the
search through a discrete space that is
really large
um is hard but you as a human are able
to do it
how how are you able to do it you have
an intuition
right you have some intuition that you
know
here uh the for example the lists appear
to be the same length if you look at the
problem
so you know you look at that and you say
well maybe there's something with the
ordering maybe the first corresponds to
the first
or the first to the last or something
like this so you have some kind of
intuition
of which rules you want to apply and
this intuition
whenever you say intuition in a program
that's a prime place to put in a neural
network
so if you know alphago or alpha 0
that is exactly what it does right it is
here
at a particular chess board right
and it could do all of these different
moves
but it cannot brute force search
all of the game tree because that would
be impossible it's computationally too
expensive
so what it does is it employs a neural
network that tells it
well this here looks promising you know
off the bat
and this one doesn't this one doesn't
this one looks promising
and so on and then you only go down
those two
and from there again you have many
options but the neural network
eliminates almost all of them and tells
you which one
looks which ones look promising so
that enab if the neural network is a
good guide
that enables you to quickly
build a program that might solve the
problem
okay so you do that you search
you search neurally guided search you
propose
programs in decreasing order
under your model so this here this is
your guiding model this is a likelihood
model
like how likely is a program given the
task that you're trying to solve you try
the most likely one first and then
you you go down so you search for the
best program
which in this case means the program
that solves the task but is also the
shortest
right the the intuition is always that a
very short program
is going to be um is going to be the
better program because it's a kind of a
simpler explanation
right so here the
the fewer steps you make in your search
that's a better program
and the more the neural network likes
the program that's a better program
because the neural network is trained
for this right so
um the best pro and you come up with the
best program
for the task okay so you choose the
program
that maximizes uh the likelihood
of the program given the task and the
library
which is proportional if you apply bayes
rule
to the likelihood of the
the likelihood that the program
generates the solution which this is
just
one or zero if you have a
if you have a non-probabilistic program
and then this here
the likelihood of generating a program
from your
library is just going to be proportional
to
the number of steps the number of
search steps that you need to make okay
so that's the wake algorithm in the wake
phase you try to
solve the problem from the training set
you
sorry you try to solve the tasks by
coming up with programs that solve them
now that gives you a data set
of solved programs right so initially
you're going to have a data set of tasks
you're going to run this through the
wake phase and
most of the time you're probably going
to fail right most of the time it's like
no
can't solve it but some of the time
you're going to succeed
so you're going to have a little bit of
a data set of where you've actually
succeeded and this data set is now going
to be
the the input into the sleep
phases so what do the sleep phases do
and the sleep phases are crucial here
because if you only if you only have the
guided search
that's already okay that's already good
right but it's not going to help you to
build more complex programs because
those are still
if you look at the program that is the
list sorting program down here like this
is so
large you can never get here with search
at least you know not in a reasonable
time
you need to construct these abstract
concepts
because this program here is much
shorter this short program is much
shorter
than the long program and you can only
get there
by building these these useful concepts
by building
up the library so in the sleep phase
we're going to build
first of all build up the library which
means we're going to take
this data set that we've constructed
like
here are all the things that we could
solve
now we're going to take that
and what we're going to do is we're
going to look at our solutions
and we're going to compress them grow
library to compress
programs found during waking okay
so here we have a bunch of primitives
this is all the stuff we can do
now we're going to see which of the
things that we use
often in combination with each other so
if we did
very often did like apply the first rule
twice
right so if we applied a plus b and then
we applied a plus b again which would
amount to a
plus a plus b which is 2a plus b
we can say since i use these two rules
in conjunction very often
i'm going to um make a new rule
in my library that allows me to simply
apply this with just one step instead of
two so i'm going to
add 2 a plus b to my library
because now since i already know i i
need those two
often together i this is simply going to
be just a single rule in reinforcement
learning this is sometimes called an
option
so it's kind of a higher order action
that you can take
and it is you know it's it's there
there's a lot of work
trying to uh get these options so what
they do right here
is sort of the same it's a compression
step so they're trying to compress
the programs that you found during the
wake phase
so here you can see an example of this
you have
a program for task one a program for
task two these
don't necessarily even need to be the
same tag like they don't need to be the
same
they don't need to come from the same
task description
right they but it's just kind of from
the same data set
and you notice that you've used this
subroutine
right here the orange subroutine in both
programs
what they do is they extract this
subroutine
into the library okay so and they have
special algorithms for this this is not
an easy thing so they have
a very efficient way to search through
these program trees
recognize commonalities and extract
those
they don't describe that in the paper
but
it is it is not a trivially trivial
thing
to do this however imagine that you can
just do this
and then you expand your library so
mathematically
you expand the library with the routine
that maximizes the following
so you essentially won't want to do two
things
this here is simply the the p
of the library itself is simply how
large the library is so you wanna
you wanna keep your library small right
if you could just add
things at will your search problem would
again become too large because you have
all these rules you could apply so you
only want to keep the best rules
but then also you want to maximize
this right here over refactorings
of the programs that you found so you
want to keep programs
again this first term simply means the
programs
actually solve the tasks that you have
um so there if it's probabilistic it's
different
but we will just say the programs need
to solve the tasks that you've
encountered
and also the programs need to be
reasonably short given your library
right and the given your library you've
already seen this before
in the wake algorithm right here this is
the same term
and the important thing is that is given
your library
right a program the sorting program up
top
isn't short it's like it's freaking long
but the the program the same program
given the library is really short
because i can use this concept 15
from the library and the concept 15 in
itself
can again use the concept 13 and the
concept 4.
so the gray box right here will be kind
of the the size
of your library right because this is
all the concept
and then the orange box on the right
would be the length of the program
itself given the library
these two things combined need to be
small
which makes sense so you extend your
library
by the rules that are themselves
small in terms of the library that are
used often
that solve a lot of problems and that
don't grow your library too much
so now that you've come up with new new
rules
um you're going to the third phase and
they call this
dreaming so dreaming this
this would already be i think this would
already be enough and they do ablations
where they leave out
different parts right here but
a thing you can do if you have
this um essentially
you have a dsl for
your problems right and what you can do
if you have a dsl is you can just apply
you can just build programs at random
right you can just take a bunch of rules
and apply them and if you do that you
it de facto generate new um
new problems to solve so
if usually during the wake phase you
have an input
x and you have an output y and you ask
yourself
which program solves
this right and these come from the data
set
but this right here is built
from a grammar right there's a grammar
which is
your library so your library builds
those programs
now what i can do is i can simply um
i can simply instead of doing the search
tree thing
i can just apply a bunch of those rules
i can just simply start here
and apply rule one then apply rule two
apply rule five and so on and that's
going to give me
a program i can apply that program
to some input data that comes also from
my training set
it's going to give me some different
output data because it's a different
program
but this now gives me another training
data point
it's not from the real program but i
don't care
right i can train my neural network
to i can train my neural network
now it's again let's find this program i
can train my neural network
to get better at finding
uh programs because i know the program
in this case
right the difference between in the wake
phase
i don't know what my program is right in
the dream phase
i construct the program so i
know what the neural network should
suggest
as my steps right here it should suggest
of all the options it should should
suggest the first one
here it should suggest the third one and
so on
so i can do supervised learning of my
neural network
to to learn to search better
in the space of programs by coming up
with my own programs and therefore
generating my own training data
that's exactly what the streaming phase
does so
in the dreaming phase um actually we're
going to take two things
so we're going to train this neural
network which they call the recognition
model and you can see
this is this is the thing that guides
your search
to predict the best programs for typical
tasks and the current library
and typical tasks means
either tasks that we sample or tasked
with the input from the training set
but you know we come up with the output
ourselves
so this what i've just described they
call fantasies
draw programs from the library so
construct the program
set task x to the output of executing
the program
and then learn learn
given x uh i want the program p
train the neural network to come up with
the program p since i know what the
program was
or alternatively i can again use these
tasks that i solved
correctly right here and i can use those
as a training data set since i already i
know
that i i just like i don't necessarily
that the program is the correct one i
just know that the program i came up
with
is uh able to solve the examples that i
had
but it's good enough right it's good
enough uh
to act as a data set as well and we do
that to keep ourselves grounded in
reality
we can't just start you know start
dreaming up fantasies because the
fantasies
it's sort of a cycle and like this is a
cycle
we come up with a library of
like a language to describe the problems
and then we use the language to generate
new
problems and then we use those generated
problems to train our neural network
if we were to only do that the danger is
that we kind of drift away
from reality and that our neural network
learns very well to search through our
imagined things but
you know as soon as something real comes
along
it's so different from what we imagined
it's it's no longer viable
that's why we also use the replays and i
think they use a 50 50 mix of fantasies
and replays
the reason why they even use fantasies
is to be more data efficient
so you could do all of these things
without the fantasy dreaming
stage by simply training the neural
network on successful
replays but that would be much more data
inefficient so
yeah it's sort of a house of cards that
you build up and i feel it depends a lot
on many things right here like it
depends a lot
on the primitives that you give
beforehand
it depends a lot on the tasks you choose
and how
well they are suited it depends on the
yeah on the language itself like how you
can apply the rules
of course the paper is trying to tell us
that the same basic algorithm
can solve a lot of these tasks but i i
still think
uh the tasks are very suited to what the
network does and the network
is or the system is built a lot with
tasks
like that in mind and that leads to the
that leads to this opportunity that you
can even do this streaming
because it you can only do this dreaming
thing
if you know if constructing
problems out of your library right here
out of your library l
is is useful for training your
recognition model
if that were not useful this algorithm
would probably work
much worse but as it turns out for these
problems it's
useful so here you see another example
of this
abstraction step so we have um
we have two tasks in the in the wake
phase that the the system solved by the
way there is
a little bit of a mistake here um
but you know we're we're humans we
we can successfully work our way around
uh
this problem which yeah
so there are you know these these um
the wake phase has actually solved both
by coming up with
programs and now the
the sleep the abstraction phase is able
to
search through a giant number of
refactorings
in order to come up with this primitive
the map primitive
right and they stress again so their
algorithm that they have for this
compression which they don't explain
necessarily in this paper but is is
able to wade through a giant number of
possible refactorings
uh to come up with these common sub
algorithms it's not as easy as simply
looking at comparing trees it's
actually much harder because you can
refactor programs in many
different ways as especially if you have
a sufficiently general
programming language like this one right
here
so ultimately it would extract this
map primitive and then you can see that
both programs immediately become
a lot shorter like the the top program
sorry the left one is this and the right
one is this once you have the primitive
they become super duper easy
so in terms of experiments what they do
is
they um they apply this
as we said to these kind of list tasks
but also to these
drawing tasks and here the primitives as
much
uh plus and minus and so on or these
languages
that you've seen the primitives are much
more like you have
a pen and you know it is at a point and
you're able to kind of
move the pen in very basic
forms i i imagine so it's sort of
a description descriptive language of a
vector graphic
and you can see right here
so this is these logographic tasks
the model writes programs controlling a
pen
that draws the target picture so that
that's just
these are the tasks the task is simply
get me a program that draws these
pictures
okay those are the tasks you can see
they are fairly
diverse so there is a lot of
things that you somehow have to have to
get
in order to be able to draw this and
when they analyze
what the algorithm comes up with during
training of
on these tasks is that it discovers
these primitives so the primitives if
they analyze the library after training
contains things like
the semicircle function so the algorithm
comes up with a function
that takes a value r and draws a
semicircle
with the given radius you can see that
depending on the value of r the
semicircle
is larger right it all it comes up with
primitives like i can draw a greek
spiral
i can draw an s curve and so on
uh it also comes up with so what you see
in c
right here so each row
um sorry each run b shows the same code
executed with different parameters
each image in c shows the same code
executed with different parameters and a
different sub
program so it is able
to to come up with higher order
functions
that so functions that take another
function
as an input in this case the the radial
symmetry
function that takes in a number n
and a lower order function and it will
replicate that lower order function in
in kind of a circle
manner so this it com it comes up with
these things
by itself now again
this is pretty cool by the way and at
the bottom you can see
what the dreaming phase comes up with so
at the beginning
you can see that the programs that the
dreaming phase comes up with are
fairly simple right and
as the library grows so grows the
complexity
of the programs it's able to come up
with so this is sort of a
built-in curriculum that the model has
it starts
but you know by constructing problems
from its own library given that at the
beginning the library is pretty
primitive
uh it you know it um
it doesn't do much but uh over time
it does now here you can
by the way i think the uh the pen starts
at the dark and goes to the light
uh like the color coding is is where the
pen starts and end
ends i'm not i'm not sure the exact
direction they stated sounding yeah it's
starts at blue and finishes at at pink
okay and you and this is during super
uh early like this doesn't need many
iterations
so illustrate the most interesting
dreams found
across five runs oh sorry no across five
runs both before
and after learning but the sort of the
iterations that it takes
aren't that many uh to find solutions to
new programs
but you can see i feel right
this is just my opinion that if you look
at the problems
and if you look at the primitives that
the thing comes up with
you probably see like i
see that the person or
the system who came up with these tasks
is constructed in much the same way
as these sort of primitives like
probably the person that came up with
the tasks
wrote a little dsl uh saying okay
you know i'm gonna you know have a
semicircle function and that's going to
be parameterized and so on
and um you know so so this
these problems themselves are sort of
generated by
already by a dsl or by a human that has
kind of
this dsl in mind and applies it and
therefore i i think that's what i said
when i said it's probably the system is
very geared towards these problems
because what it's going to end up doing
is going to end up
kind of rediscovering how the data was
generated
and that makes me a bit so so the
question now is does is this going to
work
on data that wasn't generated in this
way
or alternatively you can ask
does the universe have a structure like
this and there's good arguments like
like it can discover physical laws so
here it can also do
by the way the same thing with these
tower buildings and you can see the
primitives it's discovering
are things like build an arch build a
wall build a pyramid
like those are primitives and with
arguments and
the different arguments will give you
different
um structures right here this is very
cool
and these are the dreams down here what
it comes up with
so it's you know pretty intricate dreams
the combination
of those rules now again the question is
does this work on let's say real world
data
and i feel that is you know
is real world data does it behave
similarly
and you know maybe i don't know uh
yeah so here you can see a bunch of
ablations where they show
that if you for example if you're
missing the abstraction
you won't get very far very often
um for example in these in these logo
graphics you see pretty clearly
that without abstraction or without
dreaming
you won't you won't get very far
especially i feel that
abstraction hurts quite a bit because if
you can't abstract
you're only going to go so far in
constructing programs so you can't
construct large programs even if you
have a very good neural network
guiding your search
and lastly they go about as i said
discovering sort of physical laws and
they they sort of rediscover physical
laws
from numerical um inputs
and that's what i mean maybe the world
is actually like this
at least that's how we humans solve
problems right we
we search for a simple simple
explanation
to the things that we see and
you know science has been very
successful especially you know newton
has described no newton's second law is
like
literally the spig so
and it describes a whole lot of of
interesting physics
and you know similarly lots of other
physical
physical laws which uh it's kind of an
unsolved mystery why
everything's so simple but given that it
is
a program like this might very well
be appropriate so a program search
system might very well be
appropriate you know that being said
it probably can't out of the box solve
computer vision or something like this
and they admit that
in the um in the in the last part here
but
just look at kind of the primitives it
discovers itself
so just from the initial primitives that
you see right here like
map zip uh i don't even know what that
is like i'm not into functional
programming
uh but from the initial primitives it
discovers
the concept of subtracting vectors
adding vectors
uh dividing by two and so on
[Music]
from those it constructs things like
the square root function which
you know it's it's pretty remarkable and
from those
it in discovers things like the inverse
square
law and you can then see that for
example
newton's second law is only a
combination
of you know very few
applications of library rules so it's an
exceptionally
short program given this library
and also coulomb's law you can see it's
just kind of two
rules applied to the four inputs
which if you expand this it's a fairly
large program but because you have this
library built up
it's it's a short program
and they do an one other experiment
where they
give it so they they do
recursive programming algorithms um
like list operations again but they only
give it like the bare
minimum that according to functional
programming theory as far as i
understand it
you these are the real the primitives
you need to solve the problems
and specifically what it does is it
first discovers the fold and
unfold functions so fold is also
called reduce i think if like that's a
more common name
first it discover these these and from
these it builds
all the other ones and they say if you
go and you look
at kind of functional programming theory
that's exactly what they say
is necessary so they say given fold and
unfold you can sort of build
all the other ones and these primitives
and again you can see list difference
function
is very super duper short in terms of
this
if you have this library so if you've
discovered the zip function
and that expands to a program that is
fairly
long that you would never reach with
even with neural guided
program search okay and
not only like reaching it is one point
but then you also have to recognize that
that is actually
the correct one right and and you do
that as a human
by looking how short it is and this is
not a short program
like you could building this as a hash
table
is shorter than this program so you
would rather take the hash table
i guess if you just have two examples
rather than the program but given that
you have all this library
the zip a minus b is actually much
shorter than encoding it as a hash table
all right so they say you know the real
world data
let's say that here much real world data
is far messier
a key challenge for program induction
going forward is to handle more
pervasive noise
and uncertainty by learning more leaning
more heavily on probabilistic and neural
ai
approaches recent research has explored
program induction with various
hybrid neural symbolic representations
and integrating these approaches with
the library
learning and bootstrapping capacities of
dreamcoder
could especially be valuable going
forward
and i agree this so we
if if it's not out yet we had uh
francois chole on the machine learning
street talk
and if you if you know him he came up
with this
this arc challenge where you do like
it's almost the same thing as dream
coder does except with
these kind of pictures and you assume
that
humans have this thing called core
knowledge which they also allude to in
this paper and core knowledge is things
like
an intuitive understanding of physics
and object-ness and so on so one of the
arc challenge things is like there's
kind of a thing here
and there's a thing here
and then the solution the solution to
that is
um there's again the thing here
and
so that's the solution right
and you can already see from one example
that's kind of like a ball
bouncing off the wall and you do that by
applying your core knowledge so to say
so this again is a very
very clean data so the in in arc i think
everything is super clean data and they
say
you know if we want to apply this to
real world problems
and this is also something that surely
has said in
in the podcast which i invite you to
listen to as soon as it's out
is that we're going to have to combine
this
search so the the dream coder
it does kind of the search which
the search over a dsl so and the dsl is
learned
right now what we need this is
kind of these are different layers
what deep learning usually does is this
perception
so deep learning is really good at doing
so this is current deep learning and
this up here is what dream coder does or
generally program synthesis approaches
do
we need a way to connect the two so we
need a way
to learn these jointly because that's
what you as a
as a human some somehow do you're able
to learn
your perception model which is kind of a
perceiving model
and your your logic model your reasoning
model
at the same time or just jointly in some
way
and we haven't exactly figured out how
to do that yet
and i feel and i agree with this paper
that is probably going to be a very
valuable thing to do
all right so let me know what you think
about this paper i invite you to read it
it is it is high level right uh but
there are some other
cool things in it like the dreamcoater
learning
regxas for different uh types of numbers
and so
on but yeah i i think it's an
interesting
field it's a bit different from just
kind of core machine learning
and that was it i'll see you next time
bye-bye